all right lines a and D existed in the
original file and they're still in both
Jake and Rachel's versions so we'll mark
those as yes now let's think about all
these bees both Jake and Rachel probably
had reasons for changing it to what they
did but we don't know which one was
right the two of them will probably need
to get together to discuss which one
should go in the final version ask for
line B itself you could argue that since
both Jake and Rachel modified this line
it should definitely be removed you
could also argue that after discussing
their changes they might just decide
that they want to keep the original
after all so let's mark this is unknown
both of these are reasonable answers the
important thing to notice is that we're
not sure which version of bees should be
present in the final file